bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le mardi
12 juillet vous regardez le cette fuite
le journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition tout de suite on
commence avec le sommaire demain soir
veille du 14 juillet ce sera le
traditionnel rendez-vous du feu
d'artifice pour les habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines
les communes se prépare pour l'événement
et elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses
à mutualiser leurs moyens pour faire des
économies et proposer un spectacle de
qualité à leurs habitants nous en
parlerons avec nos invités cyan
le paris saint germain a tranché adieu
le camp des loges c'est à poissy que le
club ira s'entraîner en 2019 une aubaine
économique pour la ville nous y
reviendrons et enfin les français
l'adorent plus qu'un hébergement c'est
un mode de vie je parle bien sûr du
camping comment les professionnels du
secteur prépare la saison dans les
yvelines après les intempéries du mois
de mai dernier c'est ce que nous verrons
il fut un temps question de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines ont
pensé la commune de tireurs valait
grignon tout proche de l'emporter
finalement c'est bien là poissy que le
psg va installer son nouveau camp
d'entraînement un équipement aménagé au
bord de la nationale 13 près de
l'autoroute a13 et du centre hospitalier
intercommunal qui s'étend sur près de 70
hectares le département la ville
propriétaire du terrain aucun recours
n'est envisageable les travaux
pourraient commencer l'an prochain pour
une livraison en 2010 9 14 terrain de
football un stade de 5000 places vont
être réalisés la ville de poissy prévoit
la mobilisation de 1000 salariés une
aubaine économique
pour le maire karl olive
particulièrement actif sur ce dossier
avec le soutien également du député
david douillet l'arrivée du psg sera
bénéfique pour le dynamisme sportif
économique et sociale alors du côté de
saint germain en laye l'heure est en
revanche à la déception
saint germain avait pourtant présenté un
nouveau site en décembre dernier sans
succès c'est donc nous passons
maintenant à notre entretien nous allons
parler de la fête nationale ou plutôt de
ses préparatifs
alors nous sommes nombreux ce soir en
plateau avec nos invités pourront pour
aborder ce sujet
alors marie toussaint conseillère
municipale à montigny le bretonneux et
présente également avec moi jean michel
fourgous maire d'elancourt grégory
galali striga restiez part du maire de
meaux repas soigné à bourrer de première
adjointe au maire pour la ville de saint
cyr l'école et julien renaud responsable
événementiel également à saint cyr
l'école alors bonsoir à tous merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors tout d'abord j'aimerais commencer
à montigny le pour parler de monti le
bretonneux donc vous mutualiser les
événements donc de la fête nationale
depuis 20 ans avec la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux alors qu'est ce
qui va se passer demain à rapide
programme donc à 23 heures on va tirer
le feu d'artifice au bassin de l'adour
de riz qui est un lieu commun avec
voisins
ce feu d'artifice ont un air de fête
qu'on partage avec voisins le bretonneux
ce qui permet d'offrir un feu d'artifice
musical et à 23h30 nous aurons le bal
qui sera lui offert par la ville de foix
ça alors 20 ans vous mutualiser vos
efforts c'est pour une question
budgétaire forcément faire des économies
oui puis offrir les meilleurs spectacles
également
est-ce que vous avez des retours comment
les gens voilà apprécié cet effort comme
ils le jugent aussi les habitants nos
voisins et de mensonges ils le jugent
très bien dans le sens où le feu
d'artifice et musique un donc très animé
nous avons nous aurons dix huit
séquences musicales durant tout le feu
d'artifice ce qui permet de dynamiser
d'animer ce feu d'artifice
quand vous décidez de qui s'occupe de
quoique ce genre doit entre voisins et
montigny alors c'est décidé dès le
départ il ya une vingtaine d'années ont
signé offre le feu d'artifice ainsi que
la sécurité voisin le bal la sécurité
pour les personnes ainsi qu'une buvette
alors grégory diarrhée astier jean
michel fourgous vous c'est la deuxième
année donc vous organiser la fête
nationale ensemble comment ça s'est
passé la dernière finalement vous étiez
voilà vous l'événement était heureuse et
plus ravi des vallons d'abord nous
en 2011 donc quand on a vu en 2012
effectivement la situation économique
jce télécom il s'est fiancé l'impact des
camps vous fait chuter la croissance de
près de 0% et entendu l'impact est
direct sur les budgets des communes
donc non anticipés très vite on a arrêté
le feu d'artifice contre l'avis la
population n'était pas très content en
2012 en 2013 ou en 2014 après lorsque
mon collègue je suis garé astier a bien
sûr été élus dont ces nominations à
travailler ensemble et là on a relancé
bien sûr grâce à lui donc ce feu
d'artifice qu'on partage aujourd'hui mes
attendu donc c'est redevenu possible et
la deuxième variable c'est que on sent
bien que chez nos administrés il y a
c'est du jamais vu d'ailleurs il y à une
demande une sorte d'identité de fierté
d'être français de le drapeau national
qu'on va beaucoup plus souvent qu'avant
voilà donc il est clair que ce sentiment
ce besoin de flatter l'appartenance
française et est redevenu très fort et
donc on va pas faire autrement sous
département on peut mutualiser avec
notre collègue de de maurepas donc voilà
pourquoi à la demande aussi des de nos
administrés on a remis en place et de
l'année dernière et cette année sur le
sol organisation oui bien sûr alors
auparavant la ville de maurepas tirer
son propre feu d'artifice c'était
environ une enveloppe de 20000 euros
nous sommes descendus à 15000 euros
alors comme le disait jean michel tout à
l'heure et ajuste le triste un avis que
je partage dans cette période de
raréfaction de l'argent public ou une
baisse drastique des dotations d'état on
se pose des questions soit certain
nombre d'événements moi même dans mon
équipe on s'est posé la question de
supprimer ou pas cet événement
ça a été un débat et puis justement est
venue dans nos têtes le fait de
mutualiser avec l encours qui est une
ville a mis une vie de même où celle de
maurepas et d'elancourt se ressemblent
beaucoup issus de la construction de la
ville nouvelle et on s'est dit pourquoi
pas donc évidemment jean michel a
accepté vidéos ci et puis ça permet
d'entretenir en effet gelé dire la
flamme républicaine puis de permettre à
nos concitoyens d'avoir moment de
détente en musique
voilà avec un feu d'artifice attendu de
tous
voilà c'est beaucoup de sous comment on
lille a à peu près pour et l'encours est
mort pas c'est à peu près 25 mille euros
qui partent en 20 minutes
il est vraiment pas faire autrement
attend bien sûr bien sûr c'est pour ça
que l'idée de la mutualisation
maintenant et je pense que c'est
l'avenir même utiliser ce type
d'événement puisque finalement voilà les
feux d'artifice n'ont pas de frontières
c'est facile à se mettre d'accord voilà
qu'on a de ville pourra choisir
l'endroit où est ce qu'on va faire c'est
dans les animations
il ya une très grande proximité
donc entre maurepas est en cours dans
les associations dans les faits surtout
le secteur associatif même le marché ils
ont ils ont bien marché on essaie de
concert un marché ils sont meilleurs que
nous écoutent et voilà on danse et on
s'est donc voilà nous allons travailler
ensemble très naturellement et ça se
passe mais j'aurais simplement dire que
sur le prix en gros c'est quasiment 1000
euros la minute que les gens sachent
bien ça c'est bien que les gens aient un
peu plus de culture économique dans ce
pays
ça serait pas mal pas mal et bien qu'ils
sachent combien coûte la qui paye c'est
important donc entendu moussa faut
savoir que quand on le bloque pendant un
an deux ans et qu'elle ait raison là
donc merci à on imminent collègues de
maurepas bientôt à la gauche que nous
avons donc pour s inscrire à l'école
sonia broc dont première adjointe au
maire et je viens renault pour cette
responsable edmond c'est alors vous à
saint cyr l'événement le 13 voilà le jeu
depuis hier soir on fait tout seul on ne
mutualise pas c'est une décision qui
fait qu'il va changer ou alors c'est un
peu particulier à saint cyr d'abord à sa
série que l'on tire pas de feu
d'artifice pour la fête nationale en
temps normal on fait un bal qui a
vocation à réunir tout le monde autour
d'une identité commune autour de valeurs
communes
on ne fait pas de feu d'artifice ont
fait juste un bal et c'est l'occasion
pour nos associations d'être présente de
pouvoir faire des buffets de pouvoir
essayer un petit peu de faire rentrer un
peu d'argent public autrement que par
des subventions et c'est important
donc pour nous c'est un cetain 13
juillet qui est quand même assez
exceptionnel
il vous a pas échappé qu'il a plus un
peu au moins du rhin que notre fête de
la ville se déroule au mois de juin et
notamment début juin en conséquence de
quoi nous avons été obligés d'annuler la
fête de la ville c'est à la fois moyens
se rattraper mais c'est surtout le fait
de prestataires qui ont bien voulu jouer
le jeu qui avaient des contrats sur
lesquels ils disent eh ben c'est un
contrat et que vous fassiez ou pas faut
le payer et on a décidé en effet de
mettre ses partenaires là le 13 juillet
pour simplement pouvoir faire bénéficier
la population d
des prestations au moment du but se
traduit ce qui n'est pas plus mal
puisque il ya quand même beaucoup de
gens aussi qui partent pas en vacances à
saint cyr et c'est une bonne chose mais
sur la mutualisation mutualisent
beaucoup sur saint cyr on mutualise le
téléthon on mutualisent le forum de
l'emploi on mutualisent notre jeu notre
piscine municipale même en dehors de
versailles grand parc ar n'est ce pas on
s est donc oui la mutualisation
évidemment que c'est la première piste
de recherche d'abord pour une cohésion
du territoire parce qu'on est tous
yvelinois et puis ensuite pour aussi
pallier au manque de dotation puisque
les compétences on les a toujours
donc ça ça vous coûte comme ça une bonne
partie de votre budget événementiel cet
événement du 13 juillet où finalement
comme il ya qui emballe ça rentre
facilement dans l'eau j ai pas trop de
problèmes en fin de compte on va dire
que était effectivement c'était
l'événement de 4 juin la fée de la ville
qui était kill l'un des postes les plus
importants de dépenses
maintenant c'est vrai que nous avions
bien négocié son contrat et nous avons
pu nous pouvons proposer justement un
trait juillet qui à bas prix qui permet
de proposer énormément de d'animation de
17 heures à 2 heures du matin et c'est
vrai que toutes les familles saint
cyrienne ou être satisfaite d'avoir des
attractions pour les jeunes pour les
moins jeunes pour les ados choses qu'on
ne sait pas forcément avant et ça va
même jusqu'à la petite grand mère de 80
ans qui pourrait avoir des activités
pendant cette manifestation
donc c'est vrai qu'on a contrôlé
largement le budget 2 est-ce que tous
les gens qui viendront comme vous partez
à partir des promotions à partir de 22h
bien entendu comme chaque année alors
c'est le bal de fin le 13 juillet à
saint cyr c'est un mal et c'est un bal
qui pour répondre à votre première
question un coup entre 2000 et 2005 2009
100 euros maximum et qui propose de la
musique qui propose de pouvoir partager
de quoi manger de quoi boire ensemble et
à partir de 22 heures en effet chaque
année nous proposons des petits chapeaux
des petites choses il ya également un
mois forcément toutes les communes pour
la plupart une dernière question avant
peut-être terminée cet entretien pour
des raisons de sécurité justement voilà
il ya eu des attentats à paris en
novembre dernier ce que vous dans vos
différentes communes où vous avez pris
peut-être plus de mesures voilà c'est
quelque chose auquel vous faites plus
attention vous avez eu peut-être des
directives
alors pour ce qui ne mord pas ils
encourent nous mutualisons nos équipes
et ça c'est une grande force aussi plus
de 30 agents seront sur place technique
et policiers municipaux avec l'accord du
préfet donc là aussi et des pistes de
mutualisation et bien entendu nous
prenons l'enjeu qui est très important
et nous mettons en tout cas les les
forces de l'ordre nécessaire pour
sécuriser les environs voilà et je sais
que nous de notre côté aussi recette pas
être une mutualisation plus tôt avec le
ministère de la défense puisque comme on
l'a oublié de préciser on organise siens
et très gros feux d'artifice le 13 juin
parti à 23h30 pour mettre en valeur
l'école spéciale militaire de saint-cyr
et donc nous avons travaillé en
mutualité avec le ministère de la
défense pour toutes les considérations
de sécurité parce que effectivement nous
sommes hors plan vigipirate est
heureusement le public ne rentre pas
dans le rang sainte mesme du lycée
militaire puisqu'ils sont sur le square
de l'hôtel de ville
mais effectivement nous avons du
personnel communal qui va assurer la
sécurité nous avons aussi et dieu merci
nous bénéficions de l'opération cuirasse
kiptoon au sein même du lycée militaire
donc lewis est une sorte de
mutualisation officié avec l'état pour
voisin émotion c'est la même chose il ya
plus de dispositif via la police
municipale de chacune des communes et on
a aussi pris des sécurités
supplémentaires très bien et pas ce
serait le mot de la fin merci à tous
d'être venus en plateau d'on va
n'oubliez pas le 13 juillet donc demain
vous allez donc à maurepas et l'on court
voisin montigny saint cyr dans toutes
les communications il y à des animations
si vous voulez retrouver le programme de
toutes ces animations n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur les sites internet de
ces communes vous y retrouverez tout le
programme détaillé merci à vous toutes
autres sujets à présent c'est devenu le
mode de vacances préférée des français
depuis 2010 la fréquentation des
campings est en hausse de 9,7
pour cent alors plus qu'un hébergement
le camping c'est un petit peu un mode de
vie un état d'esprit
mais après les intempéries du mois de
mai est dernier les attentats de 2015
comment se préparent les professionnels
dont les ivy nous sommes allés découvrir
deux sitv mois vont s'organiser pour
accueillir les vacanciers
camille est lambert et nicolas landry
pour ce reportage tente traditionnelle
caravane optimisé ou bungalows
suréquipés en camping chacun trouve son
bonheur sur ce site 4 étoiles de maisons
laffitte les vacanciers arrivent
timidement une fréquentation impactés
par le mauvais temps de ce printemps et
la crainte des attentats
on mise donc sur le dialogue pour
assurer de dire qu'en fait justement les
les services de l'état font le
nécessaire pour donc bien organiser la
sécurité que nous avons donc les
garantie annulation que
voilà nous nos services ici sur place
pour donc les clients est au rendez-vous
et que donc on peut les renseigner ou
cet intéressant d'y aller voir donc des
biens les rançons charles de
gaulle-etoile situe à proximité de paris
l'établissement vise une clientèle
étrangère et propose des mobiles homes
haut de gamme
mais début juin le camping a été touché
par les intempéries 400 personnes ont
été évacuées par sécurité
par endroits l'eau est montée jusqu'à 70
centimètres par précaution ne sont nous
avons donc évacuer le camping mais
également on a on a décidé de mettre en
sécurité
certains locatif ici donc présents
pour éviter donc la casse matérielle qui
est très cher et ça à quatre jours avant
l'euro donc c'était très attention à
rambouillet même constat les inondations
ont obligé le site a fermé une semaine
au mois de juin
les touristes étrangers sont moins
nombreux aujourd'hui en tout cas on a
une tendance qui va être un petit peu à
la baisse sur la partie étrangère
entre les attentats les intempéries et
les grèves il est sûr pour la tendance
sur le bassin parisien et elle a été
beaucoup plus faible
justement le no2 de nous arriver au peut
pas nier c'est ça me paraît évident
malgré un début de saison mitigé les
professionnels espèrent doubler leur
fréquentation dès la semaine prochaine
le camping reste le mode de vacances
préférées des français
en 2015 le pays affiche à un record de
fréquentation avec près de 113 millions
de nuitées et nous parlons à présent à
politique avec cette nouvelle nomination
pour othmana seront enfin offrir un bon
soir flora notman nasri élu d'opposition
les républicains attrape élus
majoritaires à la région ile de france
il vient d'être désigné dans cette
assemblée donc au poste de vice
président chargé du tourisme et des
affaires internationales alors une
décision annoncée à part à valérie
pécresse en fin de semaine suite au
départ de david douillet pour être bien
clair un david douillet député de la 12e
circonscription ne quitte pas son poste
de conseiller régional juste cette
fonction il évoque un problème d'agenda
officiellement et ne peut assurer des
déplacements à l'étranger toutes les
semaines officieusement comprendra pas
que david douillet veut se consacrer à
sa campagne il a d'ores et déjà été
investis pour l'élection législative sur
le secteur de poissy plaisir alors on en
revient à othman al nassr fois qu'il se
voit donc confier encore une fois de
nouvelles responsabilités
une nouvelle fois le jeune élu de 29 ans
en prend du galon lui qui jusqu'à
présent on s'occupait pour la région de
la commission du développement
économique on rappelle aussi que depuis
les dernières élections municipales à
trappes où il a obtenu un peu plus de
30% des suffrages
il détient aussi des responsabilités à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines othman nasri
est en effet le président de la
pépinière d'entreprises pour nos cols ou
pas mais effectivement je fais pas de la
politique depuis longtemps j'ai un
premier engagement
savéol élections municipales à trappes
où je suis toujours élu ou n'ont pas
toujours pu vivre l'opposition
municipale cette ville en a besoin et
dont j'ai eu l'occasion de participer à
la campagne des régionales
toujours sous marin sous la houlette
valérie pécresse man hulk est aussi là
dessus
aujourd'hui il me confier de nouvelles
responsabilités j'espère que du coup je
donne une belle image aussi de trappes
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
territoire en montrant que voilà quand
on travaille sérieusement qu'on essaye
de faire valoir certaines idées et bien
il peut y avoir aussi une reconnaissance
du travail accompli
puis c'est un apprentissage moi j'assume
de dire que c'est un parcours et va pas
encore beaucoup de choses mais le
souhait de me rendre utile
je veux faire monter les jeunes qui le
maire et de ce sont les propos de
valérie pécresse donc après cette
nomination othman nation qui peut en
effet remercié la présidente de la
région qui l'épaule depuis c'est
quasiment tous premiers pas en politique
notre magna souhaitait déjà pendant la
campagne des régionales le porte parole
de valérie pécresse dans les yvelines
quant à ces nouvelles missions voilà en
quoi elles vont consister vivait dans la
crainte par la finale et au tourisme de
la région ile de france recouvrant
plusieurs l'attribution la première
avait de par la promotion du territoire
à l'international pour acculer à la peau
des investisseurs est bien sûr toujours
davantage de touristes puisque vous
savez que c'est un facteur important la
clé plus de 30 millions de touristes en
ile de france a fait vivre plus de 3000
personnes
et puis nous avons aussi des
partenariats des collaborations avec
d'autres collectivités territoriales
dans le monde donc il faut reconfigurer
pour certaines mais dans tous les cas il
s'agit de de construire dans des volumes
de co-développement avec d'autres
territoires des partenariats qui soit
gagnant gagnant gagnant simplement
économique à la fois pour lui de prendre
avec neuf entreprises mais aussi pour le
territoire l'arbre peut être en afrique
par rapport à nos partenaires en
amérique du nord où on habille également
le matin une dernière information à
présent avant de partir pour versailles
dans ce journal cela concerne toujours
la région de france cela concerne
effectivement les usagers des transports
en commun qui dispose dispose d'un pass
navigo puisque valérie pécresse l'a
annoncé ce matin le remboursement
partiel de ce pass pour les passagers
récemment touché par les grèves sncf et
par les intempéries le remboursement
sera de 20 euros sur les forfaits navigo
mois et annuelle 10 euros 60 sur les
forfaits imaginer
les 5 euros sur les forfaits solidarité
chaque mois c'est une information
confirmée par la sncf il y a un site
internet pour effectuer les démarches
nécessaires et sites internet qui
ouvrira à partir du 27 juillet mon
dédommagement point transilien.com et
prenons à présent la direction à deux
versailles depuis quelques semaines
l'association versailles montreuil
environnement lutte contre le projet de
réaménagement du boulevard de la
république dans la cité royale est les
travaux ont débuté ce lundi 11 juillet
avec l'abattage des tilleuls sur la
première partie du boulevard les
opposants ont tenté de protéger ces
arbres sont résussite nous étions sur
place à la rencontre des manifestants
regarder la première phase d'aménagement
du boulevard de la république à
versailles est lancée ce lundi 11
juillet plusieurs ouvriers paysagistes
ou le tabac tue une dizaine de tilleul
malgré la présence d'opposants au projet
nous sommes consternés et très en colère
certains sans doute n'était pas en très
bon état il fallait les abattre d'accord
mais la plupart étaient encore très sain
donc c'est un une atteinte à incroyable
à notre paysage urbain
l'abattage des tilleuls devait laisser
place à une piste cyclable des places de
stationnement payant pour sécuriser les
trottoirs et de nouveaux arbres surtout
le boulevard de la république
un projet contre lequel un recours
devant le tribunal administratif a été
déposé nous demandons à la mairie de
réfléchir et de d'entrée en concertation
avec nous et de ne pas réaliser ce
projet dont personne ne veut dans le
quartier de montreuil la concertation
demandée par l'association concerne la
deuxième partie du boulevard de la
république à partir des rues montreuil
alexis foucault jusqu'au boulevard de la
reine
il ya eu quand même deux peuples conseil
municipal là pour la piste cyclable et
l'autre pour le stationnement payant
rester sur projet est passé deux fois au
conseil municipal le fondement du projet
c'est de rendre aux piétons aux
habitants du bourg la république et aux
passagers piétons lusage des trottoirs
un usage perdu à cause des
stationnements illégaux entre les arbres
en 2017 une concertation aura lieu sur
la dernière partie du projet entre les
différents acteurs
et nous restons à du côté de versailles
depuis le 5 juillet le château propose
une exposition sur l'indépendance
américaine des oeuvres inédites sont
présentés dans la galerie des batailles
du château alors l'exposition revient
sur le contexte diplomatique entre les
états unis et l'europe lors de la guerre
d'indépendance
regardez ce reportage a signée manon
labat et william est là voyage dans le
temps au château de versailles
deux cent quarante ans en arrière 1776
la france sous le règne de louis saez
s'apprête à vivre ses dernières heures
de monarchie elle est la première nation
à reconnaître les états unis d'amérique
la galerie des batailles retrace cette
période avec l'exposition versailles et
l'indépendance américaine
on pense toujours à un engagement
financier
on pense aussi un engagement
diplomatique fort mais ça a été aussi un
engagement militaire très très
considérable et je ne peux pas
m'empêcher penser que lorsque en 1917
les américains sont arrivés avec cette
lafayette nous voilà il n'y avait pas se
souvenir chez américain de cette dette
de 100 200 français qui avait coulé pour
l'indépendance des états unis
alors pour nous cette exposition c'est
l'occasion de rappeler dans quelles
circonstances cela s'est déroulé quel
était le contexte international
quelle a été l'ampleur du conflit qui
est beaucoup plus immense considérable
que l'on ne pense puisque ça a été
véritablement un conflit mondial
l'exposition cible le contexte
diplomatique de l'époque
en regroupant des oeuvres venues
d'angleterre de france et des états unis
chaque pays raconte son histoire son
vécu il ya beaucoup d'oeuvres inédites
il ya beaucoup d'oeuvres inédites et ça
c'est vraiment il ya eu un travail de
recherche de documentation absolument
considérable sur le sujet c'est vraiment
un regard tout à fait nouveau et à ma
connaissance c'est la première
exposition qui sur le sujet veut avoir
cette diversité point de vue une oeuvre
inédite l'aigle de diamants prêté par
l'ordre des saints sinatti l'objet est
offert par les officiers français à
washington
juste après la proclamation de
l'indépendance américaine l'aigle n'est
jamais sorti des états unis sa venue en
france est en elle même un événement
l'exposition est à contempler jusqu'au 2
octobre
solidarité à présent parcourir 3000 km à
pied à travers la france est le défi que
s'est lancé cyril maurice une course
courageuse qui réalise au profit de
l'association rêves présent dans les
yvelines depuis quatre ans cette
association a déjà réalisé sans rêves
d'enfants gravement malades à l'hôpital
new de versailles comme rencontre un
sportif assister à un spectacle ou
encore visiter disneyland paris
alors monsieur cyril à maurice est parti
de chez lui le début début avril sa
course comprend sans étape avec une
moyenne de 40 km par jour
aujourd'hui il s'est arrêté place
d'armes à versailles
qu'est ce qui la pousse à réaliser une
telle course que représente
l'association rêves les réponses au
micro de fanny bourdon à l'époque mon
fils était malade dont qui s'est fait
opérer il ya trois ans maintenant ça va
mieux et donc la rencontre avec d'autres
parents et voir voilà tout c'est tout
c'est titi m'a vraiment marqué donc
c'était un des premiers facteurs on va
dire à dessiner ce projet et par la
suite moi j'ai eu un petit accident
sportif donc je me suis reconverti dans
la course à pied et donc je me suis
associé aussi avec un papa qui a une
petite fille qu'elle leucémie justement
est donc au fur et à mesure j'ai
augmenté mes km justement pour atteindre
vraiment la discipline bas du marathon
et donc je voulais vraiment alliés voilà
c'est ce côté humain et sportif et c'est
comme ça que le projet s'est dessinée
l'association rêves
elle existe depuis 1994 et le réalise le
rêve des enfants très gravement malades
dont le pronostic vital est engagé
aujourd'hui elles et réparties dans
toute la france il ya 38 délégations qui
sont implantées et il ya 700 bénévoles
qui oeuvrent tous les jours pour pouvoir
récolter des fonds et permettre donc les
rêves de ses enfants
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis rester avec nous
tout de suite vous retrouvez n'aura dit
nein pour le dernier set 8 sociétés de
la saison il sera question du
baccalauréat certes il encore à quelque
chose à quelque chose pardon c'est ce
que nous verrons point je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau numéro du journal
je vous souhaite une
en soirée